- [Narrator] This is what
the war in Ukraine looks like
on one of China's most widely
followed state media accounts.
(booming sounds)
The Wall Street Journal analyzed
nearly 70 Ukraine-related videos
that were posted since the
start of the war in February.
The account has also been
amplifying Russian narratives,
like calling the conflict
a special operation
and not an invasion.
(presenter speaking in foreign language)
(soldiers speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] These videos
also reminded followers
to watch Russia's Victory Day parade
and the Russian president
appeared five times more often
than his Ukrainian counterpart.
This pro-Russia perspective
is just one message that's been echoed
on Chinese state media
and getting shared with a wide audience.
- I do think that's kind
of a propaganda opportunity,
or persuasion opportunity
for the Chinese government.
- [Narrator] We examine how
closely Chinese state media
is aligned with Russia,
despite Beijing's
efforts to present itself
as a neutral party to the war in Ukraine.
(sirens ringing)
From day one, China hasn't
outright condemned Russia
or taken part in Western
sanctions against Moscow.
- China-Russia relationship
has been growing closer.
- [Narrator] Maria Repnikova
is a political scientist,
fluent in Russian and Chinese
and she's been monitoring
how Chinese state media
has been reporting on
the Ukraine conflict.
(people clapping)
She says their pact has gotten stronger
as both countries' relationship
with the US have gotten more contentious.
- [Maria] So we see this
kind of increasing closeness
of their ties as one fact
to the geopolitical relationship itself.
- [Narrator] And examining
how the war has been covered
on Chinese state media
reveals Beijing's tilt
towards Russia, like the
People's Daily account
on China's version of TikTok.
In the nearly 70 videos
published on this account,
which has about 150 million followers,
none of them show destruction caused
by Russian forces or describe
how civilians cope with
the ongoing fighting.
14 of the posts are clips
from China's Foreign Ministry,
which often repeats a
common line from Moscow
with dramatic music.
(presenter speaking in foreign language)
- Some reports, the way they frame
or kind of explain pro-Russia stance
is often very much in this anti-US,
anti-NATO rhetoric.
- [Narrator] There are 10 clips of Putin
and they also echo a similar sentiment.
(Putin speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The decision
to single out sound bites
like this show a deliberate attempt
from Chinese state media
to paint the West as the villains
of the Ukraine crisis.
Meanwhile, only two videos
of Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
made it into the feed,
and both clips show him
saying Western leaders
aren't doing enough.
(Volodymyr Zelenskyy in foreign language)
- [Narrator] People's Daily didn't respond
to a request for comment.
Some Chinese state media organizations
have been getting specific directives
on how to cover the war.
Two days ahead of the invasion,
an online video platform
that's part of a larger
state-backed publication posted this
on Weibo, China's equivalent to Twitter.
It appeared to be
instructions for its staff.
The memo said posts that are unfavorable
to Russia or pro-West
should not be published.
The post was later removed from Weibo.
The company and Horizon
News didn't respond
to a request for comment.
- This leak, what it's maybe showing us
is it kind of this attempt to maybe yeah,
spin this war in a particular direction?
- [Narrator] Journalists
in China are limited
in what they can write about,
which can be observed
on the country's primary
international news network.
In one news report posted
on CGTN's Facebook account,
which has more than 118 million followers,
two journalists documented their journey
from Lviv to Kyiv.
- Just one hour journey from Kyiv.
- [Maria] They're not allowed
to be maybe too sympathetic
or too pro-Western or too pro-Ukraine.
- We definitely see more debris, ruins
after brought by the conflict and crisis.
- [Maria] And they have to
kind of say it's happening
but they're not able
to provide the context
or maybe include more footage
of various victims that
would provide the context.
- [Narrator] CGTN did not
respond to a request for comment.
Much of that context was missing
from Chinese state media when mass graves
were discovered in the
Ukrainian town of Bucha.
The incident triggered global condemnation
with many countries calling
for an investigation
into alleged atrocities
committed by Russia.
- There's nothing less
happening than major war crimes.
Responsible nations have to come together
to hold these perpetrators accountable.
- [Narrator] But the
story was largely ignored
by most Chinese media outlets
while the Kremlin called
videos from Bucha fake
without presenting any
evidence to back the claim.
Beijing described the images
of the civilian deaths
as deeply disturbing but warned
against making quote, unquote,
"unfounded accusations."
As the war stretches on,
choosing not to condemn
Russia for its actions,
like in Bucha, can put
Beijing in a tricky position.
- China still very much cares
about its relation with the West,
especially for economic reasons
but I think it's very important
to not necessarily ruining
this competitive edge
by over-aligning with Russia.
- [Narrator] So Beijing
has officially maintained
a neutral stance amid the war
and this diplomatic position
hasn't contradicted what's
been published on state media.
- It's definitely using
it as an opportunity
to assert its stance and its rise
as distinct from and arguably,
also counter to the West,
questioning the world, the US,
critiquing the US.
- [Narrator] So as long as the US
is portrayed as a global troublemaker,
the war in Ukraine remains a useful tool
for Russia to justify its invasion
and China to boost its image
to audiences at home and abroad.
(dramatic music)